[Music]
we all know the place the magic mushroom
house is the tight white pants excuse me
and all the different attitudes our tea
parties frenemies worrywarts sometimes I
just feel blue Kraig's shade throwers
nosies so what's going on with you and
there's one thing they have in common
100 good old dudes now for the one
finger push up one - except for one high
heels but what if they were more to the
story
two days ago I saw someone who looked
like us that's impossible and they drop
this map what if they were never alone
if there really are other Smurfs out
there we need to find them
what if this means the lost village is
an alleged oh now you're talking about
maps and mystery Smurfs what's going on
in here none of your business
nosey well alright
brainy sappy clumsy oh that's not even
convincing I don't do well in the
darkness I have enough trouble in the
daylight I didn't think the last village
was gonna be this hard to find whatever
you do don't eat all your rations I just
made all my Russians
we're not in smurf village anymore wow
wow wow wow
The Lost Smurf Village it's time to take
a road trip I'll be like Babur
oh they'll be all like oh no I'll be
like funny that's what I call talking
out of your butt
we have to find the village before they
do incoming
ah huh oh we mean you no harm
we're looking for the loss I'm really
freaking out you guys Smurfs the lost
village
[Music]
you